hi
so today i will tell you about our
efforts
to develop antibody best treatment for
kobe 19.
first of all just let me tell you who we
are
so iibr is a governmental
cutting edge a resourceful
institute that specialized in the fields
of biology chemistry
and environmental sciences and
we have national and international
collaborations in the biology
unit division we focus on studies
of different bacteria toxins and
viruses so let's go into
antibodies so we wish to
to have to let the evolution do its best
to to make the best antibodies
and the way that the evolution do it is
by
affinity maturation in vivo so it starts
with a vdj general combination
and then upon exposure to an antigen
there is a somatic hypermutation
mostly in hot spots across the
cdrs region the parts of the antibody
that binds the antigen and
the resulting antibodies have improved
affinity
and upon the second or third exposure to
the same antigen
these whole cycles go on and on until a
very high affinity antibodies are
reached
mainly in the reaching stealing affinity
of
the of the in the nanowire range
so in our group we isolate
hyaphene antibodies that enable specific
neutralization
and successive detection of the target
antigens
mostly toxins viruses and bacteria
and our methodology is to obtain
peripheral subcultural lymphocytes
from human patients or from immunized
animals
and then we isolate hyaphine antibodies
using
fat display libraries we generate
a full-length antibodies and
characterize them
just a quick overview of our methodology
so this is the antibody we are talking
about the viable region
that is expressed as a single chain both
the vehicle and the vehicle aspects of
the cyclogen
a and a antibody on the surface of a
filamentous
phage and protein phage we create
a library that contains hundreds of
million different
phases or different antibodies and then
by
process termed pending we
select only these antibodies that
specifically
bind the antigen this process can be
repeated several times in order to
enrich and specifically
isolate the desired antibodies
the way to develop a or to create
such a good library is to amplify
the genes that encodes to the whole
variety of antibodies from the donor
both to the heavy chain and a viable
religion
and to the light and viable legends we
are talking about both the lambda
and the kappa in order to do this we
have
a specific and very um
large repertoire of primers for each
specie we then
assemble them randomly together to
create
two libraries one for the heavy chain
with the lambda
a trains and the second for the copper
chains
and then we sequence many clones
of each library in order to ensure that
it is
a a diverse we we're using
a the sanger sequencing sex studio
um system and just for example
after a second round of planning we we
test a random
clones from the library and as you can
see
there are several clones in each library
that bind
to the antigen and after the third round
most of the clones usually bind the
antigen
some of them with a very high affinity
we then reformat the antibodies for
to a full length a igg so
this is the an antibody so we are using
for all our antibodies a constant
region human fc igg one
type a region
to which we join the variable regions
that were derived
from the phase display library at the
end of the planning process
we then express these antibodies intro
or in heck to nine three cells purify
them and
further characterize basically
in our laboratory we are focusing on
a on by pathogens
that are a biothreat associated
but in the last few months we have
isolated a panel of human antibodies
that we hope will serve as the basis for
combined post-exposure therapy for scope
to infection
so star scope 2 this is the virus you
are all
well familiar with this we are
specifically
want to target the spikes and what we
aim to do is to isolate antibodies
that target different epitopes on the
spike
protein so we obtained the
lymphocytes from a recovered impatience
we also obtained from a humanized animal
but today i will
focus on our human
antibodies we created the library
and now we we are characterizing using
the antibodies
so we have found the rivalry using the
receptor binding domain
this is the the moiety of the spikes
that specifically bind
uh the human h2 receptor
and we cloned the the resulted
we we sequenced the resulted clones uh
reformatted them into a igg
and by the end of this project we ended
up
with eight different antibodies that
belong
to a different germ lines both for the
heavy
and for the lichens
this antibodies specifically bind
to the receptor binding domain which is
part of the
s1 region of the spike
as you can see it does not uh by that
they are not binding the a
and terminal domain for example we then
wanted to uh measure their affinity
so we are using octet it's a bio-layer
interferometry system the antibody in
question
is immobilized to the sensor
and then we add the the
the antigen in this case rbd a different
concentration
and we measure both the k on and the k
off
part and and then we can calculate for
each antibody
the the the affinity the the kd
and as can be seen here all our
antibodies
have a quite good affinity which is in
the lower
and even sub and anamola range
we also ask whether our antibodies can
bind
the antigens simultaneously or in other
way walls
whether they bind to different epitopes
so we again are using the octet system
so the first antibody in question for
example md65
is immobilized on the sensor and then we
add
the antigen in this case the s1
and as you can see upon binding of the
s1 there is a very nice
a shift of indicating for
the binding to the antibody and then we
wash the
the axis and then we add another
antibody
so if the second antibody binds to
different epitope
on the antigen then it will result in a
another wavelength shift as shown here
if it's bind to the same epitope
then we will have no a further a
shift so we characterized
all the antibodies and
we could classify them into four
groups two of the groups
only are represented only by one
antibody
and two groups have three antibodies
and basically what we are
seeing here is that the the small
moiety the receptor binding domain
contains at least
four different epitopes we then asked
whether these antibodies can neutralize
the the virus
we are using in vitro system to test
the neutralization on a on a veil cells
and as can be seen here basically
seven out of the eight antibodies
can can neutralize the virus we have
also
added here a control antibody the rb18
and isotype control and just want
you to focus on our best uh
neutralization
a neutralizing antibody md 65
which belongs to the second group and
also you can see that the antibody
62 from growth three
is also a a very
high neutralization potency
we then ask whether we can say something
about
the mechanism of the neutralization of
these antibodies
again using the octet so the first
antibody
is immobilized sensor and then we add
the receptor binding domain and then we
add
the receptor recombinant receptor
human h2 and we test
when we test whether this receptor can
bind
to the rbd in the presence of the
neutralizing antibody
so we took a represent a representative
antibody from each group
and as can clearly be seen here
is that for example antibody 29 belongs
to group
1 does not inhibit
the binding of the receptor to the rbd
and so does antibody 47
while two of our best neutralizing
antibodies
antibodies 65 and antibody 62
completely abolished the ability of the
receptor to bind to the ability
so this can tell us about
the most important maybe most important
part
of the buy of the of the neutralization
a
mechanism needed for a saskatchewan
please bear in mind that antibodies
47 and 29 both
inhibit the activity of the virus in
vitro
so i guess uh maybe
probably two other important
mechanisms
so where we are now so we are continuing
to characterize the activity of the
antibodies
in vivo in animal models we also
perform for clinical evaluations of
pharmacokinetics
toxicity etc we are currently also
characterized another set of human
antibodies
and antibodies that have been derived
from a saskov to
immunize the animals
and with that i would like to thank the
people in my group
and all the other people who helped us
to the anti-active and
engineering group and to our colleagues
from the biology unit and thank you all
for listening